if there's one thing movies are good at
it's blowing things up
it's fun it's epic it's total Cinema
baby tell me you got that I got it I got
it since the beginning movies have been
a canvas for showing off explosions and
that tradition lives on to the present
day the marketing for the movie
Oppenheimer shows that the promise of an
explosion is itself enough to justify a
ticket purchase so it's something
moviegoers love to talk about and yet
there's almost no discussion about the
meaning of those explosions why do we
love them what purpose do they serve and
in our favorite movies what deserves to
be blown up to get to the bottom of
movie Kabooms there's first one rule
you've got to learn
[Music]
at the 2009 MTV Movie Awards The Lonely
Island released the music video cool
guys don't look at explosions pointing
out that despite explosions looking cool
it's uncool to look at them
[Music]
this Trope is so common because it
combines the spectacle of an explosion
with narrative fulfillment it's not just
a cool explosion but also the appeal of
seeing our cool heroes succeed they
don't need to turn around because
they're so confident in what they're
doing and this Trope goes as far back as
the Bible in Genesis 19 God destroys the
city of Sodom because of the evil living
there and instructs lot and his family
to walk away from the explosions without
looking back while fleeing Lot's wife
does turn around to look so God punishes
her by turning her into a pillar of salt
so according to the Bible looking back
on God's destruction is not just uncool
it's a mortal sin because it shows a
lack of faith in the certainty of God's
commands so in both the Bible and in
action movies the impulse to look away
from the explosion shows the narrative
has a Biblical certainty to it it means
the hero is so sure of their actions
they don't dare commit the sin of
thinking twice in the movie Shooter Mark
Wahlberg is wearing a hat as he walks
away from an explosion in this movie he
can walk away with confidence because
he's blowing up the cabin of the film's
antagonist a U.S senator seemingly as
wicked as the city of Sodom he not only
frames Wahlberg's character in a
criminal conspiracy but also perpetuates
brutal war crimes overseas explosions
like this one visualize the complete and
utter destruction of an objectively evil
villain thanks to an explosion a story's
climax is no longer some abstract
element of the hero's journey but rather
an epic climax we can see with our very
eyes ironically the explosion in shooter
is completely unnecessary Wahlberg's
character already killed all the men in
the cabin so the explosion exists not
for some functional purpose but as a
clear symbol that Wahlberg successfully
destroyed corruption in Washington like
many Revenge movies he fulfills the
fantasy of cleaning house giving us that
satisfying conclusion that according to
the movie itself we don't often get in
real life Justice does not always
Prevail it's not the wild west where you
can clean up the streets with a gun this
idea of a clear and Swift Justice
explains why so many iconic movies end
with not just explosions but the
explosion the cool guy saving the day so
clearly and spectacularly so not looking
at explosions serves three purposes
first it shows the hero's absolute
certainty in their mission second it
shows the clear defeat of some
antagonist and third it's awesome
but in movies explosions aren't all fun
and spectacle in some cases you're the
target
[Music]
throughout the atomic age the world
lived with the very real threat of
nuclear Annihilation and that fear
extended into popular movies movies like
Godzilla War of the Worlds and later
Independence Day show aliens destroying
cities which according to the original
Godzilla's director served as clear
parallels to the destruction of an
atomic explosion let's not think that
monster movies are ridiculous but make
movies from the perspective of hatred
and amazement at the horrors of the
atomic bomb so in contrast to cool guys
don't look at explosions movies about
the atomic bomb often show destruction
from the perspective of the victims
instead of cool guys looking away from
explosions it's innocent people looking
at them and facing the brutal
consequences
the movie Barefoot gen based on the
comic of the same name has one of the
best and cruelest depictions of an
atomic explosion in movie history
showing the explosion and aftermath of
the atomic bombing of Hiroshima in 1945.
all the stylistic choices feel like the
complete opposite of the cool guy
looking away in the scene the initial
explosion is not some epic set piece but
it's instead viewed objectively from a
bird's eye view far away from the city
at first the bomb doesn't create some
spectacular effect in fact it actually
removes color from each shot
desaturating them into black and white
we lose all audio time slows down and
each shot is simple and static for
emphasis we watch several locations lose
their color further distorting Time by
putting the initial explosion on Loop
but then focused on a girl with a red
balloon the sound and color returns as
colors stream chaotically across a
moving background and dynamic shots of
melting civilians zoom in and out at
random I'm using screenshots here
because the original footage is so
disturbing but I'll link it in the
description from here we move from
individuals to the landscape seeing the
physical destruction the bomb causes and
now we get a third color palette not the
original regular palette or the black
and white but now in intense saturation
as even the matte painting in the
background physically tears apart this
sequence in Barefoot gen feels truly
apocalyptic the combination of random
changes in color palette the Distortion
of time the move from Silent to loud and
all the many objects and people moving
in different directions challenge our
preconceived notions of how explosions
feel to The Victims of Hiroshima it's
not a single blast but an onslaught of
changing color motion and sound when the
cool guy walks away it feels like a lot
obeying God's command and fulfilling
God's will of absolute certainty but
those in Hiroshima are the victims of
the city of Sodom and we the viewer are
Lot's wife daring to look back at the
Carnage
Barefoot gen shows the gulf that exists
between explosions as fun spectacle and
explosions felt by innocent people but
many movies find their moral alignment
somewhere in the middle such as the
famous Flight of the Valkyries scene in
Apocalypse Now in the scene U.S soldiers
bomb a village in Vietnam and like
Barefoot gen the scene does highlight
the victims of the attack showing
fleeing children and unarmed civilians
but the movie runs into conflict with
itself because of how spectacular the
explosions feel it's hard to tell
whether the famous music in the
background satirizes the brutal attack
or it makes the scene more fun to watch
making the soldiers feel like certain
Gods punishing the Sinners of Sodom
especially since the Flight of the
valkyrie's song is a piece from an opera
about the heroic Valkyries in Norse
mythology preparing for a final
apocalyptic battle in the movie Jarhead
soldiers watch this exact scene in
Apocalypse Now and actively cheer it on
clearly endorsing the destruction in the
movie within a movie as director Francis
Ford Coppola himself has said an
anti-war film cannot glorify war and
Apocalypse Now are arguably does but
some movies use this conflict between
spectacle and Terror to their advantage
the movie Paths of Glory has one of the
earliest examples of the cool guy not
looking at an explosion but at the same
time that scene shows the futility of
War by wasting his heroic certainty on a
lost cause in the movie Major General
brawler orders Colonel Dax and his men
to charge on a well-defended German
position a suicide mission that will
inevitably fail and after it does
brawler puts random soldiers on trial
for retreating the movie shows the
pointlessness of War by showing not some
distant evil but an evil within the Army
itself at one point Major General
brawler even gives orders to drop bombs
on his own men to get them to advance
exacting a god-like wrath as punishment
for any soldier's uncertainty in the
mission so Colonel Dax is bravery
amongst spectacular explosions is all
for nothing challenging the very idea
that such certainty has a place in war
both Apocalypse Now and Paths of Glory
capture the Dilemma faced by War films
finding the balance between engrossing
spectacle and senseless violence lots of
movies have to walk this very fine line
and if you look closely the real meaning
of the explosion does often get lost in
the spectacle it actually happens so
often you may not even notice it the
movie Die Hard Stars John McLean a New
York police officer who tries to stop
German terrorists from taking over
nakatomi Plaza in Downtown LA the movie
openly critiques capitalism satirizing
the nakatomi corporation as a cruel
company exploiting people around the
world a project in Indonesia contrary to
what you people may think you're going
to develop that reason not exploit it
when the terrorists do take over the
building they get compared to
businessmen business is business you use
a gun I use a fountain pen what's the
difference and through this lens our
hero John McLean acts as a clear foil
he's a blue-collar worker from New York
City bewildered by the White Collar
party full of champagne and kissing men
instead of business attire he wears a
plain tank top and walks barefoot as he
literally climbs up the corporate ladder
to the top of the building to dispose of
the German terrorists the movie clearly
pokes at America anxieties about
corporate greed the encroachment of
foreign capital and the flagrant
unregulated economy of the 1980s but I
want to suggest that the explosions in
the movie tell the real story like many
action movies there are several cool
explosions like one at the bottom of the
building and one on the roof but
crucially nothing actually gets
destroyed nakatomi Plaza stays
structurally intact and the deputy chief
describes it as simply property damage
unlike shooter or Barefoot gen nothing
really gets destroyed here it's just
there for spectacle's sake and I don't
have a problem with an explosion being
there just to be cool but Die Hard shows
how an explosion can get in the way of
the messaging of the movie the dialogue
tries to critique capitalism but the
explosions show how the movie doesn't go
very far in that critique if the movie
were really anti-capitalist the
explosions would have destroyed nakatomi
Plaza the obvious symbol of cruel
capitalism that the movie openly
challenges but because the building
remains intact it's not really rejecting
capitalism John McLean isn't a hero
destroying corporate greed instead he
shows that all we need is a blue-blooded
American to take charge and show the
foreigners how it's done Die Hard is an
excellent action movie but a close look
at the actual impotence of the
explosions shows that the critiques
really have no bite and American movies
have a long tradition of tepid
capitalist critiques in their explosions
recently Glass Onion and the menu
feature explosions and I won't spoil the
details for those that haven't watched
but for those who have consider how
those explosions work so hard to
critique the ruling class but in the end
their explosions don't really challenge
existing power structures they just get
rid of a few bad apples at the top and
leave the system intact and it's for
these reasons that I especially
appreciate American Psycho which is also
a critique of capitalism but at least it
uses explosions not to create some false
sense of critiquing an oppressive system
but rather it uses explosions to
acknowledge the absurdity of Patrick
Bateman's situation that he can Cruise
as a vice president and go so far as to
kill people all in a system that lets
him get away scot-free of course not all
movies have to have some Grand critique
but on the other hand it was very
refreshing to watch the movie How to to
blow up a pipeline which has the same
suspenseful cinematic explosions like
the ones in Die Hard and the explosions
actually raise interesting questions
about the validity of destroying
property to make systemic change you may
not agree with the methods or the
politics of the movie but regardless
it's exciting how the explosions in the
movie actually create a conversation as
opposed to laughing at a fun but
powerless satire which brings us to the
toughest question of all how do you
balance spectacle destruction and
politics with the most spectacular the
most destructive and the most political
explosion in human history America
dropped the atomic bomb on Japan not
just for its ability to destroy cities
and kill people in Mass military
officials also knew that the spectacle
of such a large explosion like the
spectacle of explosions in movies served
a huge amount of the impact so even in
real life explosions we share that same
conflict between spectacle and cruelty
between narrative certainty and
narrative ambiguity and that's what
makes explosions a fascinating but
terrifying concept because it's not just
what blows up it's who and it looks like
the movie Oppenheimer will explore that
exact idea the marketing of the movie
like the bomb itself promises the movie
Magic spectacle of an explosion of
biblical proportions while also
exploring the moral dilemma that such a
device introduced
the destroyer of worlds but don't take
my word for it now you see it
[Music]